today's topic the liam neeson incident
tell you a story this is true
i'm not going to use any names but i was
aware make him back
and she told me she had been raped
but she handled the situation of the
rape
in the most extraordinary way but my
immediate reaction was
i asked did they did she know he was no
what color were they she said
it was a black person
i went up and down areas where the cash
hoping i'd be
approached by somebody i'm ashamed to
say that
and i did it for maybe a week hoping
some black
would come out of a pub and have a go at
me about something you know
so i could kill him
it was horrible horrible when i think
back but i did that and i've never
admitted that dude i'm saying it to a
journalist
but for a bit
it's awful but i did learn a lesson from
when i eventually thought
you know and i come from a society i
grew up in
northern ireland and the troubles and
you know i
i knew a couple of guys that died on
humber strike and i
bet acquaintances they were very caught
up in the troubles
and i understand that need for revenge
but it just
leads to more revenge and more killing
and more killing
you know ireland north known as proof of
that you know
all the stuff that's happening in the
world the violence is proof of that
you know ever since it's happened a lot
of people have been clowning liam neeson
especially black people
uh we have charlemagne the god donkey of
the day yeah kev
i want to know what did you think about
the holy sit thing and more importantly
what did you think also about the
backlash
well the thing about having the backlash
i knew the backlash was about to happen
well there's racism there's lashes
anyways
that was good me i'll be honest with you
the most surprising story about part
about this whole thing
is i didn't know during the 1960s there
were black people in ireland okay
how did the [ __ ] even end up there i
don't think liam neeson's racist
he only does movies where he kills white
people
and wolves white wolves and to that i'm
not going to boycott that
you feel bad liam neeson is the reason
we're talking about why i don't like
crime okay
i i [ __ ] with him that's an ally right
there okay
whenever people bring a black old black
crab like uh
you know that like liam neeson is the
titanic of uh action movies
really and the titanic they get a whole
bunch of white people
he always kills people with the most
ghetto items you'll use like a pen
and a paper clip or condom i'm like
goddamn right here he might look middle
class but he kills like he's from the
ghetto you know what i'm saying
he'd take a paper clip is sticking in
your eyes
like go back to school [ __ ] he did
something 40 years ago bad people that
were like behind
uh giving heart and were like you know
what kevin hart sent some pretty foul
[ __ ]
and some uh homophobic [ __ ] nine years
ago he already apologized for that
let's forgive him keep the same energy
he did something 40 years ago right
something that knows that it was bad
some racist
[ __ ] that was racism because that was
raised him at his best
and people were gonna say stuff like oh
kevin just said something
and this guy walked around kevin was
telling those jokes on stage repeatedly
he toured around the country where he
was telling people if i had a gay son
i would do this or that to him so let's
not make it sound like kevin didn't do
something and it wasn't far
more recent than liam neeson and let's
not also forget that liam neeson openly
admitted it while kevin was found out to
have these tweets i think
people have missed why the conversation
has gone the way it's gone
i think more than anything black
people's wounds go very deep
and so when they hear this story they
have
flashbacks to racist incidents and
people who did attack them
yeah people who did say racist things
what liam neeson was thinking
those people were also thinking but they
acted upon it so they have all these
images of that dark history and i will
admit this
black people we are the most forgiving
people on the planet
right there is no group of people who
have had more harm done to them
and have had to turn the other cheek
than black people it is always what
we're encouraged to do
and it's always what we're demanded to
do you know in america they have these
discussions about reparations for
slavery and white people are always like
we would never as americans and look i
don't even want reparations for slavery
it's fine i'm gonna figure it out myself
that being said i find it ironic that
white americans will say something like
that like never
reparations never yet after world war ii
they paid
reparations to japanese who were stuck
in internment camps
over a hundred thousand of them were
given twenty thousand dollars each
for the suffering that they served in
those internment camps
japanese people were only there for four
years do you imagine what would it be
like
if black people all got reparations
for 400 years worth of trauma man we
would all be able to afford a family of
white slaves okay
i'd be giving those [ __ ] a hard time
like hey tanner [ __ ] lawn
use them scissors yeah oh it ain't got
power use that white power bi
all this to see we are very forgiving
people and i also recognize that a lot
of black people today are fed up
they're tired of having to educate
others she's tired of having to look the
other way
turn the cheeks the fight is not over
but we also have to understand that more
than revenge what we need is progress
more than revenge what we need is
healing more than revenge what we need
is an honest discussion
and the only way that can happen is if
we
tell the people who are benefiting from
the system to come forward
and tell the truth without consequences
because as so long as they know that
there's going to be giant amount of
consequences
for telling the truth they will continue
to shield the system that keeps them in
place
right because there is no way that most
people would tell the truth if it meant
their own destruction
and i would look no further than south
africa apartheid
they have to go through truth and
reconciliation to begin to heal the
country why
because so many people would've gone
missing so many people had died
and without answers as to why and
without the truth
without discussion without accusers
without victims facing their their
perpetrators
without that kind of dialogue the
country can never move
forward and so the truth and
conversation i don't have no problems
right now no they definitely do and it's
not perfect
but it allowed for a lot of people to
grieve to finally have some closure
to finally have that discussion and
address the fact that you know what
there is a tremendous amount of racism
here we're all going to try to deal with
it as a nation and we're all going to
try to move forward
and i think the world needs that our
relationships need that
we're too busy trying to self-preserve
ourselves to tell the truth and leonison
in a moment of vulnerability told the
truth about something that he felt was
disgusting about himself
here's the thing liam neeson and the
reason you are getting donkey today uh
your friend
got raped by a black man therefore the
only black bastard
you should want to kill is the black
bastard who raped your friend
did we not riot and pillage and attack
people
discriminate after the romney king what
are you doing here a young woman
a looter tried to explain what has been
going on in this dreadfully troubled
city
it's a way for people to bend their
frustration
and then they're like targeting like
korean-owned businesses and white
businesses
looters of every race and color just
like their victims
22 years down the drain
i mean can people realize what they're
doing is wrong
this is not the way to overcome racism
people have that innate desire to
understand
the people who are coming out and saying
this man is racist boycott and all this
stuff
claim to be progressive and what is one
of the biggest progressive and leftist
mandates
that we don't have punishment for people
in prison that we focus on
rehabilitation
on one hand you want to be open you want
everyone to talk more you want bigger
dialogue you want less emphasis on
punishment
on the other when someone utters a view
that's different from yours you
immediately you punish listen if we're
going to be honest that we're going to
be open and we're going to talk about
some of the darker stuff i'll share
something
there was a time in my life when i was
18 where i had a group of friends who
would indiscriminately go out
and punch people in the face at night
clips okay i'm not proud of it i'm not
happy about it but it would happen
and i remember one night i decided not
to go out with the boys i didn't want to
go out
and they ended up paralyzing somebody
putting them in a wheelchair okay
that to me to this day is very
reasonable i've never engaged in any
kind of crime
i had the desire to potentially want to
go out with them and engage in that
stupid behavior but i decided not to
okay do i deserve to now be lambasted
and to have my entire life derailed
because of an idea
and a thought i had 10 years ago yes
because i was horrible
of course not we were angry kids and
that does not justify the fact that i
did that when i was 18. don't get me
wrong i think it was trash
and to this day it's always something
i've regretted which is why today i am
the least violent person you'll ever
meet i have not touched
and put my hands on nobody in so many
years i want to stay that way
but it's only because i went through
that experience and i came back from the
edge that i can say that about myself
and i think what we need to do is
encourage people to come back from that
ledge
let them know that there is a way back
because redemption is human history
and if we don't give people a space to
have redemption
then why are we even trying why are we
talking let's just keep fighting let's
just fight let's just fight all this
right now [ __ ] me and you i hope i hope
that we as a people can really start to
move forward because i'm tired of this
rhetoric where
anytime someone says anything that's
edgy immediately we go straight to
boycott we're going into cancel culture
this is someone that was coming forward
with a dark memory
we all have some preach has some i you
know i shared one i think
we can do much better in terms of
healing if we all allow ourselves to
talk about these things
or dark because we all have these dark
sides to us and i think the strength of
humanity
is not that those sites don't exist but
that they do but we still choose to be
good
in lear of that what do you think
[Music]
you